um
[Music]
i created a tiny url for my talk but i
realized now that for people who walk in
late it's going to disappear so let me
write it down
there's a tiny
url
okay this is not super important so
so let's start so this is uh thanks for
coming back uh this is part two of the
tutorial and i'm going to be talking
about concave games so the world is
going to be very nice
for this hour
the utility functions are going to be
concave
in a player's own actions
equivalently the loss functions of the
players are going to become vects in
their own actions
so just to remind you the thread of the
whole tutorial i'm going to be thinking
about in general
multiplayer games
and
simultaneous
decisions made by these ant players
eight flare has their own loss function
or equivalently utility function
and the main question i'm going to be
asking is uh you know if there are
simple methods like online gradient
design or variation of that
is there joint behavior going to get
somewhere meaningful maybe a nash
equilibrium correlate with or some other
interesting solution comes up
uh last hour i met i made the
distinction the important distinction
about whether
the utilities are convex concave in
their own in one's own actions or not
uh and uh as i was saying just now i'm
gonna focus on concave games for this
hour
in concave games
um
nash equilibrium
is intractable in general unless the
game is
special
so i will
mostly be focusing on either special
games like two-player zero-sum games
or solution concepts that are tractable
in uh
attractive like correlate equilibria or
minimizing regret okay so this is
our focus now
so in particular i'm focusing on this
left hand side of the
board
and i'm going to be discussing two
questions
is there a way to modify the training
method
so add bells and whistles to gradient
descent ascent
to remove these uh spiraling around and
away from the equilibrium behavior that
we saw even in very simple cases
orthogonal question
oscillatory or not i'm interested in
what are the optimal rates
via which
online learning dynamics converge to
equilibria these are the two questions i
want to talk about
[Music]
uh okay so that's uh
you close the microphone
thank you
all right so as i was saying these are
very nice games and we know a lot of
things about them
so maybe the most fundamental theorem
about these games is uh
when the uh
function that defines the payment of one
player to the other player so this is a
two player zero sum setting one is when
it is convex and concave
and when the constraint sets are a
product so each player is
can choose from you know player can
choose from max the other player got
just from y
the players do not impose on the
feasible actions available to each other
then you have fundamentals mini max
theorem so the min max equals the max
min so simultaneous and sequential are
exactly the same things
[Music]
the minimax uh optimal solutions are
essentially unique
and they are unique if the function is
strictly convex strictly concave
and you know you've seen this picture uh
you know what you're trying to do is to
find a
saddle point the global subtle point
these mean max points are equilibria of
this game where one player is paying the
other
lxy dollars
uh
all right so this theorem was proven by
von neumann about a hundred years ago in
fact
for neumann was inspired by a paypal by
mirbor and milborel exactly 100 years
ago
[Music]
um who showed this theorem for
i believe
games with up to
four
so so he was looking at games with
four pure actions per player and he was
considering
sets that are simplicities over those
you know four or five actions per player
and he established the theorem
he conjectures that the theorem is not
true if people have players have more
than four or five actions so far neumann
disproved that a conjecture showing that
this theorem is true
generally
yeah it's historical question out of
curiosity the way that in the case that
you remember in the case that you have
seen the paper
how did she try to prove
the special case i don't yeah i don't
remember
uh all right so other things we know
about it is when your loss function is
by is bilinear like this one
and your constraint sets are
polytops um
computing
minimax equilibrium is equivalent
polynomial time equivalent
to solving linear programs
which is the archetypical convex
optimization problem
if your function is a general convex
concave it's equivalent to convex
programming so there are intimate
connections between
optimization and
minimax equilibrium computation
this this problems are intimately
related as uh
these results imply another interesting
fact is that um
so you know from neumann and dantek were
talking to each other when von neumann
was developing the theory of linear
programming
during their discussion von neumann
laid out a theory of strong linear
programming duality
so when dantik was writing his book
he had a construction trying to show
these equivalents but that construction
was incomplete and it was only recently
uh completed
this computational equivalence between
the two problems that's an other
interesting historical facts
in any event more connections with
optimization came out of the literature
online learning and now regular learning
so we know that if players of a zero-sum
concave game okay so this function is
convex okay so if players of a of such a
game
each run their own no regret learning
method such as multiplicative weights
update or online grading design
their joint behavior will converge
to equilibrium
but this convergence is in quotes okay
so for the following reason
the convergence is
really the one you see here so it is
convergence in the average sense
so the
uh it's convergence in the sense that
the moon converges to the earth so
the average of the trajectory
goes to the min max equilibrium
but it's not necessarily the case and
you know this is what's happening here
that the last iterate is converging to
the equilibrium in fact later it
very typically
oscillates around and away from the
equilibrium hits the boundary and
oscillator on the boundary
and this is very typical of no regret
learning methods such as
grading decent percent
multiplicative weights update follow the
regularized leader you know all these
methods
and it's perfectly fine right so if if
all i'm trying to do is to compute the
equilibrium from a
perspective of a central uh planner who
wants to understand what's going to
happen in the game that's perfectly fine
maybe it's not fine if uh
you view this uh online learning as a
a model of uh behavior of agents so then
it's not exactly clear
uh if you know agents uh
would uh use a method that uh
uh oscillates around as opposed to kind
of like identifying an equilibrium of
the system it may not be it still could
be
um and you know the question is can the
oscillations be removed
so let's zoom into this picture that we
have here
so here's what's happening this is our
starting point
you get a gradient push you go to this
point
okay you get a gradient pus you go and
so and so forth
um
and and you know the point is that when
you see
spiraling around an away behavior you
know what's happening is really the
momentum of this grading decent ascent
dynamics is wrong
it pushes you away from the target as
opposed to towards
uh the target right
and the question is you know like are
there ways to correct that momentum
um
you know
you know uh and then there are ways so
there are classical methods to do so
uh so so so uh a few years back with uh
vasilis and andrew and zayn
uh we uh you know we're thinking about
gans and we decided to to you know
we proposed this question and you know
we identified methods that uh are known
to cl you know from classical methods
that are known to
exhibit this last uh etheric convergence
so here's one
due to pop-off which is called
optimistic grading decent ascent
uh what this does is uh
you know without the pink is the
classical grading descent ascent
dynamics
but what the pink does it is
undoing
a little bit of yesterday's gradient
right so at step t
at half the step size
i am undoing and i'll explain why you
may want to undo this
um in many ways so but you're undoing a
little bit of yesterday's gradient
similarly
uh the maximizing agent is undoing a
little bit of yesterday's gradient
so in our picture
the effect of that is sort of like uh
rather than for example pushing down
here to to go further away from the
target you'll be adding negative of the
of the estrogens gradient to your
current
push so ultimately you may hope to
correct
the bad momentum that your dynamics has
so this is the pictorial this is the the
picture
of the idea i'm going to show various
explanations for why this works okay
this is the picture explanation this is
a proof by picture
i'm going to show you another two proofs
okay
so this is a proof by picture that
by i'm doing a little bit of yesterday's
great and you know i may hope to correct
the bad momentum
and go closer as opposed to further away
from the target
uh as i was saying uh
this method is classical it was proposed
by popov 40 years ago
and there's an even older method related
one by corpelevitz 25 years ago or so
uh uh so popoff is written here
extra gradient is written here
and i'll explain what these two methods
do
uh uh by showing pictures okay so these
are the steps that happen in optimistic
grading descent ascent
uh so what i'm doing here is i'm
representing the pair of points the pair
of iterates xt and yt by zt
for conciseness
and by f of z i'm representing the
gradient field right which is
uh great in respect to x
minus greater respect to y because
one is trying to minimize and one is
trying to maximize is the right thing to
do
so what happens in ogda is you do the
following so at the current iterate
you um
do
you know you compute your gradient
uh field
and consider that point
but you're also
taking the difference between your
current gradient field and the one at
the previous iterate
and you do the joint push so you go you
travel to this point as opposed to this
point that gradient descent ascend would
do
now why would you want to do this
this goes back to the question that
manolis asked me earlier
which is someone only said okay like if
you're spiraling away around and away
from the equilibrium wouldn't you want
to run the steps backwards
to go towards the equilibrium
that's called the
you know that has a name all right so
it's called the proximal point method
where
that you can show works okay so in the
in the proximal point method
you want to push
towards the gradient that you don't have
okay so step t plus one
you wanna subtract your uh future
gradient okay so this is these are
called implicit methods because to run
this you have to solve a fixed point
problem to run this method
and it's expensive typically so what
ogda tries to do
is to approximate the gradient that you
don't have
with a current gradient
it's a first order approximation with
the current gradient
and uh
the uh you know first derivative of the
gradient
right and if you use this approximation
in this method you basically you recover
this method
so this is what ogda is trying to do
trying to approximate this proximal
point method makes sense
there is a factor of two missing
in the approximation no so this is the
approximation you take this and plug it
into here so you get data here you need
a net over two
yeah so you typically these methods
actually are a bit slower compared to
because you lose this at this factor
all right so what does extra gradient
target do it's also an approximation to
proximal point a different one
so here you do the following you're
sitting at the current point
you compute your
gradient
you go there compute another gradient
and use that gradient
here to go to travel to your next point
that's also an approximation to
approximate point different one
where you now instead do you say look
i want to approximate this by
just you know in my head doing an extra
step going there seeing the gradient
there and using that now okay so this is
the approximation do here
so this is the motivation for these
methods
all right so now if you believe me that
this corresponds to running the dynamics
in the reverse order thereby converging
to equilibrium
and if you believe me that these guys
are approximations
to
those backwards dynamics then that's
another proof
of why you would hope this method still
converges
last literally converge to equilibrium
so that's the second hand wavy proof yes
that'll give you
and uh yeah i mean i don't know if this
is folklore but but uh
it was recently used in a paper by
maktari
to analyze these methods and establish
some rates of convergence what was
classically known is that these two
methods and and that goes back to a
question that mike asked
what was known classic from classical
results is
asymptotic convergence
asymptotic class literal convergence of
these methods to the minimax equilibrium
and also rates for the average of these
two methods the average iterate so so
both these methods we know results for
the average iterate
also maybe the best iterate and
asymptotic only for the last literate
okay so that's it that's that
opportunity means uh in the same sense
that i mentioned earlier like the
average of the trajectory like this
object
this object
versus this object
this is the difference i'm talking about
yeah
so spiraling around the equilibrium
satisfies that this converges to the
equilibrium but not that this converges
all right so i i kind of like showed you
a figure i hand waved by this work i
decided to give one proof in my whole
tutorial
precise so
i want to show you why this
has average iterate convergence with
rates and also asymptotic
like a formal proof
question
well i was thinking that
if you're
far out we'll just have to define the
potential part
yeah
well potential functions are very useful
in optimization uh but yeah
okay
all right uh oh before i do so though i
mean i i'm sure i've shown you the
methods in the unconstrained domain like
you know you can implement all the steps
that i have in this picture i wanted to
also define them in the constraint
domains
so um the first thing i want to do is
actually
replace this method by this method
right which also has the form of like
you know getting this half step
right and uh so you know you know
it's not uh hopefully right so this
method has this half step explicitly
right so this half step is this point
here so you move you go to that half
step right here and here these two
equations
at that half step you compute your
gradient
and then you go back to your original
point
uh original point
original point
and you make that push right so
uh you can similarly write this in that
form
it's a little bit different okay so
the gradients are always the same but
you you know you you know you do
you have uh
you make a step uh in this you know half
time in the half interval and also in
the you know integral
or whatever
um but you know so this i mean if you
sum this up you will see that it
recovers the this
dynamic now once you write them in this
way
uh you can define their projected
version so here is a projected version
when my constraint set is a product
constraint so both you know for for
every gradient step
you project to the constraint set for
both players
you do the same over here every every
gradient step just project to the
constraints
if your constraints are coupled you can
do the same right i mean you just write
everything in terms of z
right so you you know you use this z
which is
the you know the pair of the variables
so you know you have now this very nice
form okay so you
uh okay let me actually change it to any
constraint set so
you know you do a half step so you go
the previous half step you take a grade
you do creating with respect to zt you
project with the constraints
then you go back to this half
point and uh interpolation point and you
you know do another grading step with
respect to the original gradient
um and next are gradient uh is similar
like as shown in the picture so these
are the
these are the methods in the constraints
the strain case
and you know these are all known to
asymptotically converge to the minimax
equilibrium
so now let's try to prove it can you
read these letters kind
of so i wanted to fill it all in one
slide so that's why i wrote it small
all right so there's a so i write down
the potential so here are the dynamics
i'm reminding you right so like
there's this interpolation point
you have this interpolating points
and the actual points
right again you do a gradient step from
interpolating point to the next
interpolating point
and then
you compute your real new iterate by
going to that interpolated point and
then another greatest step respect to
the
original gradient
so
i'm going to write this potential
function down what is this potential
function
at time t
and at any point z of my interest in my
domain
is just the sum
across all time steps of the inner
product between my gradient field and z
i minus z okay
it's not clear why this is a good
potential but i'll show you that if you
make this small you're in good you are
in good shape okay so if you make this
thing small it's good
all right but let's postpone that
discussion for now
in fact for the whole slide i'm not
going to use the fact that i'm in a good
game like for the whole slide here
i'm not going to be making any use that
of the of the game being concave
all the computations i'll do here are
generic
i'm only going to use that in the next
slide but so for now
in fact i'm not even going to use the
fact that this is a great interval test
this is any any map any any any
multivariate map
all right so i wrote down this potential
and then the first step is kind of a
silly i just
take i you know attract the difference
in my potential
which is exactly the last term of the
sum which is here
and then i take this last term of the
sum and break it up into three turns
okay
uh which are written here
and uh you know i mean uh what i did
here is uh i subtracted
uh this guy from here and now i have to
correct that
over here
and also uh
then
you know this is another correction okay
so i didn't remove some stuff
those are the three interesting terms
that i'm going to underline with
different
lines to keep track of them okay so
there's going to be colors here to help
you parse the groove so what i'm going
to do is i want to
bound this okay
and i want to bound it by bounding these
three terms
let's start with the let's see which one
do i do i think i do the
last one or the middle one the middle
one
is this the last one the last one yeah
the last one you're right i cannot
yeah
anyway
so
let's start with the last one okay uh
i'm a backwards guy right uh okay so
like uh
one is disturb
now claim that from the definition of uh
this update
you actually have this inequality that
for any point z in your domain
this inner product is bounded by this
so let's try to see why this is true
i didn't prepare the right picture here
so let's see so
i have this update
all right so i guess there are two cases
for this update either you do projection
or you don't
if you don't do projection this should
be trivial because
uh you know
there's gonna be some equalities there
so let's do with projection
so
with projection what's happening is that
kind of like that you know
you know this is the projection of this
point so you know you know you have this
point here it's on the boundary because
you did project this set s you projected
what did you project you projected this
point
well this is not a good projection
project at this point
so what does it mean that this point is
the projection of this point it means
that if you choose any other point z
in your domain
this angle
is how you say in english obtuse
okay
this angle here doesn't choose
so which means that the difference of
this guy and that
inner product
this minus that
negative for any z that you chose inside
the domain
okay and if you rearrange that you you
know i promise you you'll get this one
uh okay so you got that
next step is to
[Music]
inequality
so as it turns out this inner product is
this is a very common trick people do
um
this inner product
is actually the difference of a bunch of
uh differences squared okay so you
it's this minus that squared
minus this squared minus this chord this
is a very common trick
okay so this you get this one from there
by analyzing this uh middle term
you get an analogous statement
and now i'm gonna do some color coding
so to help you
so the
uh purple term is the difference of the
interpolated points in one step
it appears here with a negative sign
here with plus sign
this is the difference of your
uh arbitrary point that you chose
here this point here
uh with the two interpolated points
different ones but you know these terms
are gonna survive uh together till the
end
and then you have the red one which is
the difference of the next interpolated
and the
zt
and zt and the previous interpolated
point
the correlation point okay so these are
the
two things you can write i mean i don't
know how much you can parse out of this
i mean it's gonna be
it's gonna be an algebraic manipulation
so i don't you know
i'm not gonna offer you i offered you
two
pieces of intuitive evidence now i'm
gonna do some algebra
okay so you have this and you have that
and now you have to analyze this inner
product
so for this inner product you're first
going to do because she's verge and also
remember this is the only thing i'm
going to use in this slide about this f
that f is lipsets it's london lipsticks
which came from the fact that what i'm
thinking about is a smooth problem
yeah
so i do cause
and i have basically this difference
uh l to norm and that difference l to
norm
and alice came from coming from the
lipsticks
and uh okay so i do here some triangle
inequality replacing this difference
with you know these two distances
and then i'm gonna be
applying young's inequality
to
upper bound uh you know various
products with a bunch of quadratics and
you know trying to recover
you know differences squared that appear
upstairs because i want to add them up
and cancel things out
uh
all the bright manipulations and details
don't really matter
the signs are important
right so
it's important that this cancels that
these guys are going to survive
and then what you want is
that this minus a half
is going to try to kill this guy
this other red thing
and this minus a half is going to try to
kill this guy okay so
if you
try to implement that strategy
and you add these three
inequalities
what it gets is this nice thing that
my potential function in one step
uh can be upper bounded by
something with a negative sign
right on a coefficient hopefully i'm
going to set the step size so that this
is actually positive so this whole thing
is negative
another thing with the negative sign
the the difference that i claim from the
beginning that is going to survive
and
[Music]
this difference here so and my plan is
to telescope this one and to telescope
that one okay so
telescoping everything details don't
matter
arrive at an upper bound for my
potential at step t
where you know
i've just summed up this
i summed up that
i exploit the fact that these are
consecutive differences of the same
object so i telescopic
and similarly for that so
long story short
if you also initialize that the first
interpolated point is equal to the
starting point you get a nice upper
bound of your potential function written
here which is a bunch of negative stuff
the difference of
the arbitrary point z and the first
interpolated point
z and the current interpolated point
and uh this negative term so
effectively you have a bunch of negative
terms
and just this difference between the
your arbitrary z and the original
interpolated point
and your
arbitrary z with the current
interpolated one these are the important
features of this right a bunch of
negative stuff
and this is the only interesting uh
piece of information on the right hand
side
good so i copied it here so now we're
ready to actually prove average case
convergence okay so
again
not much intuition you can get out of
here except that
yeah what i want to get is i want to
bound each of them with differences of
quarter of of differences squared
and i want similar terms to appear so
that i cancel things out and i
i have a bunch of negative
terms on the right hand side
so that is going to be my handle
uh so how do you show after you have
that how do you show average case
convergence of optimistic grade average
case optimistic grading
well the first thing to do is to to make
sure that these things are actually
positive so that these are actually
negative terms so this is what's done
here
if you set your step size to be
one over your
smoothness this is the right constant
uh you get that all of these guys are
negative
so the only thing you're left with is uh
non-negative is this thing on the right
hand side
so
for any z you plug in then
the maximum that this potential function
can get
is the maximum that the single positive
term on the right hand side can get
which is the radius of your constraint
set
in this you know l2 squared
this this the notion of radius of your
constraints
right and that's it so you get you get
that you know the
normalized uh
the maximum of
points in your set
of the normalized potential function
divided by t
is upper body by some
something that depends on the size of
your constraint set
over t
that's the important thing that as you
grow t that can get smaller and smaller
and smaller and smaller
as much as you want
and now
the question is why is that a good
potential to have right
and uh okay so let me now unpack why
this is good
so now i'm going to remind myself what f
is so so far i haven't used it i only
use that it's it's lipsticks
i remember that f is my gradient uh
field right so minus greater respect to
x so plus greater respect to x minus mu
to y
and i'm going to remember that uh this l
here is convex concave again this is the
first time i'm going to use it
right so now i'm going to use the fact
that my potential is as small as i want
it to be my average potential is as
small as i want it to be
together with two facts to argue that
i'm close to a mini max points
so how do i get that well
um
you know this is just the definition of
this
let's finish my potential it's
normalized
so i didn't do much here i'm just using
the fact that this thing is smaller than
this thing
now i'm unpacking it
replacing f with what it is
so it's that that's inequality
and then i'm going to use a convexity of
l with respect to x
and concavity of value respect to y
to upper bound to lower bound this by
this and upper bound this by this
so you know so you get some
cancellations here this term that term
cancel out
so i get the average over times
of uh
right so x is an arbitrary xy is an
arbitrary point of my iterate with my x
iterate against that y
my y thread against rx and that's
basically the duality gap so
if i do jensen again
i get that the loss at the average x
against this arbitrary y
minus the loss
of an arbitrary x against the average y
is upper bounded by this quantity that i
can drive to as small as i want it to be
and that's it
okay so you bound the duality up by
whatever you want
and that thing drops like 1 over t
as long as you set your learning rate to
be something over this movement this is
this is the whole proof
for the average case convergence right
so ultimately
what i get here is the average points
right so that's the proof of the average
case yeah
[Music]
so i have here the
asymptotic one as well
i'm not sure i wanted to spend too much
time on it but let's uh
let's wave some hands
i'm not gonna do that
last iterate
goes to the point rather than just the
average
excuse me
the limit
okay so let's see what i did here so i
now pick z star to be an arbitrary
minimax solution
and um
okay so i guess i'll do a few things uh
okay so remember when i was telescopic
before from t down to zero
here i'm only telescoping between some
little town some big town
that's again telescoping a bunch of
negative terms
and now you know these blue terms are
not
from
the equal zero all right this is the tau
right where i started my telescope
so that's important there
second important thing is that i'm
taking this star to be a minimax
solution
uh and uh by the previous analysis if i
plug in uh
uh to this difference of my potential uh
z star of course this is equality all
the terms are that are
in here and not here this is the sum
from t tau plus one to t
the inner product so that's just the
quality and now by the previous analysis
and because this star is equilibrium you
know this is lower bounded by zero so
that the duality gap is zero at the
z star point so i get this inequality
which long story short
because this is bigger than zero i can
plug it in here
to get that this whole quantity there
is no negative so this is this i
rearrange this
to have that my equilibrium against the
interpolating point at time t
is upper bounded by the
my equilibrium
at the interpolated point earlier in my
uh iterations
uh this positive term and a bunch of
negative terms
and uh here's now the observation right
that
this sum skip like as t goes to infinity
i keep adding negative stuff
but you know because my domain is
bounded these terms cannot go as like if
i take all these terms to the right to
the left side they cannot also be coming
smaller and smaller
so it must be the case that these
sequences go to zero
because if they don't i will be adding
stuff to the right hand side
it's going to the right side is going to
be coming smaller and smaller smaller
well these guys there's only a finite
amount they can you know go down so
these sequences
must actually
go to
zero okay
and that doesn't mean that the sequence
necessarily is not obvious that this
implies that the sequence converges
but okay if you do another three lines
that i want to do because you know it's
going to get too heavy
this is three trivial steps but uh
the sequence does converge to the z star
equilibrium okay so i'll let i will i
have posted these slides you can
study the last houston so again this
does not imply that the sequence
converges
but
uh you can actually do a little more
thinking to show that it does converge
to the z-star
equilibrium was that a question no any
other questions about this
this went a bit fast but again
all the details are on the three slides
that are presented it's not like more
exotic arguments like
some algebraic manipulations clever of
the bright manipulations to get
an up and bound on your potential
function and then you uh
do some extra work so this is general
for
variational inequalities this year this
is the there really is a bigger
breakdown here yeah
it might be helpful to comment um
you know the proximal point method is
really what's here the rest of this is
numerical kind of a discrimination of
that particular method so what you
really sort of say is proximal point
method is a good method for solving an
equivalent class of problems that's
right
your formula is a variational inequality
but proximal point method was developed
for optimization
your whole setup here was for
oscillation in mini problems
why is proximal point good for that
because the rest of it is just numerics
the ogda or the texture radiology
particularly integrated right so i guess
the intuition for that is that it goes
backwards like it does this spiraling
away and around and away it does it
backwards
now analyzing the proximal point you
still have to analyze it to show that it
actually does
that
yeah oh yeah sorry the question so uh
mike asked um
uh could he provide some intuition about
i mean
you know i said earlier that this is
trying to approximate the proximal point
method
uh could you provide information about
why the proximal point method uh you
know does the job you wanted to do
and i guess my answer was that uh
intuitively the proximal point method
tries to do the
um
iterations backwards in time
with this implicit update that it has
but yeah like showing it you still have
to do some algebra
to show that it does
so yeah so i decided to present the
algebra for a method that actually is
not implicit but yeah
that's right yeah i i don't have uh
honestly too much more intuition to
provide yeah
i'll get to that
yeah
oh so young asked
do i know the rates so these arguments
are synthetic
dba to the minimum solution
do i know uh
race i'll talk about that in the next
slide actually
so okay so classical work establishes
average convergence rates for these
methods and other related methods
and asymptotic converges results without
rates
or with like not effective rates
uh
uh in the case you know again that my
functions know that's okay what do i
know about trade
there has been a lot of recent there's
an explosion of recent work trying to
figure out the rates of elasticity
uh most of that work has started the
unconstrained settlement
so we know some very well the rates for
the outcome string set
so for the constraint setting we have
bounds but they're not
i mean you can already recover some
bounds from these early words
but they're not effective in the sense
that their dimension dependence
is not good okay so the time dependence
is good but then
in front of that that is about
dependence on the dimension
but one open question
that is interesting to think about is
in the constraint setting
getting algorithms or showing that these
two algorithms
converge
uh
with a rate that is polynomial inversion
and
the iterations that you make
so that's a very interesting question
that i
didn't know the answer to
until uh maybe like 40 minutes ago when
the young guy told me that
yeah told me that
they have an analysis of the extra
gradient method
with this uh
dependence
now what i told young is that we
shouldn't announce it until the end of
the program so that we show that
something
could happen
okay but uh let's say that there are
partial answers to this question
another thing we know
and i think this was a paper
uh this was shown in uh this paper and
that
is that
the elastic convergence rate for this
method is going to be slower in terms of
time compared to the average rates
so the average rate i've showed you for
this method the 1 over t for the average
uh the last letter is going to
definitely be slower than one over
routine
and i believe this is what the young guy
show you this paper so for this method
it is indeed one over three times some
uh mild dependence on the smoothness of
the dimension
i don't know if you want to specify more
okay all right
uh let me move on to multiplayer games
for like the last 10 minutes of this
presentation
uh again i'm still in the nice uh
same thing about nice games
so your pmp functions are all concave in
one one's own
utilities those functions are for the
facts in one's own actions
and uh okay so what do we know about
this game so a common domain is that uh
nash equilibrium tractable
but the new government i wanna make here
is that currently the equilibria are
tractable in very gently for very uh
under very general conditions
uh and i wanted to illustrate this
result by uh
garden and jiang and leighton brown
which provides a general computational
framework based on the ellipsoid method
uh so not practically uh
not so practical but
definitely in terms of complexity the
problem is well understood
so they provide a general computational
framework for games of what are called
polynomial type what is that
these are games where the number of
players and the number of
pure actions so these are against a
finite number of pure actions
uh where people can randomize over their
actions
so
these actions are basically of simplices
every person is choosing a randomization
as you know like a point in the simplex
which corresponds to an optimization
over uh deterministic strategies
so for that special class of games
uh the the the thing about game support
number time which means that the number
of players and deterministic strategies
that are available to each player
uh they're polynomially many
in the description in the in the coding
in the binary encoding of the game
and the other thing that they want is
that given a mixed strategy for its
players so given
x1 and simplex external simplex and so
on so forth
there is a polynomial time algorithm
polynomial in the description of the
game and the description of the mixed
strategies that can compute the expected
payoff of every player
so their claim is that if you have any
game with these two properties
polynomially many players and strata
pure deterministic strategies per player
and a polynomial time algorithm that
profits expected payoffs for product
measures of mixed strategies
then
there is a generic algorithm called
ellipsoid without hope
uh that computes correlate equilibrium
the interesting thing is that
if you think about it
a correlate equilibrium is a joint
distribution over deterministic
strategies for the players
so
correlate equilibrium the object that
you're trying to compute lives in a very
high dimensional space exponential
potential exponential in the description
of the game
so what ellipsoid without hope does here
is to identify
a low description complexity correlate
equilibrium it doesn't just compute a
correlate equilibrium which could be as
i said an exponentially large object
right you have polynomial prayers before
normally many studies each in the
description of the game so the joint
strategy profiles are
number of actions to the number of
players right so these are exponentially
many
however the method identifies a low
complexity one so that's pretty cool
that it does
uh
here's an example of games that are
pulling normal time
these are graphical games so these are
games where players are nodes of a
network say sparse network
and the player's utility depends only on
the strategies of the players that
he interacts with
so that's a game where you know the
number of players is as many as the
number of nodes in the network
every node has a finite number of
deterministic strategies and
you can easily compute expected
utilities for a product measure of
strategies so that's a good example of
these types of polynomial type games
an example of games that are not of
polynomial type
are extensive from games which is the
game theoretic model of
turn-based games like poker and go
and chess
right
because here
i mean it depends on how you describe
the game i guess but um but yeah even
even if you lay out the whole game tree
the number of deterministic pure
strategies are exponentially mainly the
size of the tree
uh
stochastic games which is a game
theoretic model of multi-agent rl is
another example where
uh the total number of deterministic
policies is exponential in the
description of the
game so these are not games that can be
handled by this method but a lot of
other games that are useful and
interesting can be handled by this
method
right so it's an interesting method to
have in mind
when you think about correlation in
multiplayer games
um
yeah
i understand that polytech games is
somehow the way that the theorist will
describe a general kind of game
out of
[Music]
curiosity
i see why someone would try to use the
ellipsoid like
the tcs version of a gradient for the
two players
does anyone try to implement something
like interior point method in order to
achieve better rates in that kind of
stuff yes i want to discuss this next
but but so people have not uh okay so i
don't know i do not know how to
implement the interior funding method
for that
but but of course i know and that's what
i'm going to discuss in the next slide
uh algorithm is based on wanna get
learned is there
no triple number in the pcs uh
[Music]
uh and the question was i guess yeah
okay implied by my answer yes
so there may be a whole set of course
for they will be yes
can you target a specific one
not with this method yeah you can
maybe optimize certain objectives
but not uh
um
you cannot optimize any uh
you know as general objectives as you
can when the game is uh
to play a game which you know
it's it's a
you know
easier
an easier problem
in this in this function
yeah
yeah five minutes okay uh in terms of uh
more practical algorithms this is
so you know it considers the dual of the
correlate equilibrium uh computation
problem which is
trying to compute an exponentially big
object considers the duo
are the dual uh the weights the
primarily set up the deal is invisible
it runs ellipsoid on any feasible
problem so the ellipsoid is going to
prove that the dual isn't feasible
and
the hyperplanes that the ellipsoid uh
uses to to show that the dl is invisible
are used to zoom into a local
plexi-correlated equilibrium for the
primer okay roughly speaking this is the
idea but it does use the ellipsoid
algorithm is not so practical
so how about practical algorithms well a
generic way as i was saying earlier to
converge to correlated or to course
correlate equilibrium
is by doing no regret learning such as
uh
so have every player run
by themselves their own uh no regret
learning algorithm
such as online graded design
multiplicative weights update follow the
regular as either follow the perturb
leader and so on so forth
in fact this no regret learning is used
in uh you know
recent successes in the practice of
solving difficult games like uh
it is used in the heart of the libratus
algorithm that beats humans in poker
now what do we know about no regret
learning in multiplayer games we know
that
if agents interact over t rounds
then each of them experiences a regret
that scales like root t
for not having cho you know
fixed
fixed action in hindsight
which
effectively so
equivalently reflects a rate of
convergence to course correlate
equilibrium
that goes down like one over root t
um and the question is you know how much
can you push this rate of convergence
the obvious bound upper bound on the
regret in a game setting is constant
the op which means that the obvious
lower bound in the rate at which the
empirical play converges to corollary
equilibrium is one over t
so there's a gap between
what we know
which is one over rupty and and you know
what the obvious lower bound is which is
one over t
so the question is can you get uh can
you can you get this one already all
right so
as it turns out the
you know this negative momentum methods
that i was you know talking about in the
beginning of this hour
are very useful to get closer
to the obvious lower bound in
the bounce how much
the regret should go
there's a line of work uh that uh
one you know uh celebrated paper by
basilis and company showing for example
that in general games
if you use a negative momentum method
rather than root the regret you can get
it down to two to the quarter
okay so you can improve on the obvious
one that you get for against adversaries
so in a game context
so
opponents are not like adversaries okay
that's the meaning of the slide so this
this is tight
if you play against adversaries
but if you play against players
who are trying to optimize their own
utilities you can beat this root t and
get a t to the one fourth if you use one
of these
optimistic gradient methods or related
methods
uh in fact uh you know some recent more
recent line of work showed that in
two-player games you can even get t2.16
while some old work that we had
had shown that in two-player games okay
much more specialized class of games you
can even get down to polylog t so
question is you know like
where is the answer okay what's the best
how much can you push this technology
so a a very recent you know work of my
own
uh shows that actually you can get poly
log t in general something so in
arbitrary games you you can come up with
methods and these are you know uh
methods like optimistic grade and design
percent
whose regret scales like poly log t over
t rounds of interaction which means that
uh
the you have near optimal converges to
corollary equilibrium
so in this work
we saw course correlated equilibrium but
in some folder paper we we also show
that for corollary equilibria
so don't have too much time to talk
about this proof uh it is on the slides
that are shared but let me give you the
idea in two
points
there is this that
when all players use negative momentum
like optimistic grading descent descent
then
the lost sequence that uh a an agent is
experiencing
is smooth not only is it smooth so not
only the loss
functions that the player
experiences
change slowly
but something more than that they
they're higher or they're smooth so you
can they're really really smooth okay
and uh
against uh really really really smooth
uh sequences of losses
[Music]
negative momentum
does a great job in minimizing regret so
this is roughly speaking the intuition
okay so
when let me let you say it another way
so
uh
what's happening here is this that in a
game setting
everybody is using their own variation
of you know
you know so their own learning algorithm
now
that learning algorithm depends on the
past experience of the player
and you know like in one step that
experience doesn't change very fast
okay so what they're going to do in the
next round is close to what they were
doing in this round and close to what
they were doing in the previous round
and so on so forth
and if you add to that
you know rather than a standard no
regret learning algorithm you
have them use this optimistic variance
they're even you know smoother the the
sequences of actions of the player even
smoother
which means that their opponents are
also facing really really smooth
opponents
and it's such a smoothly changing
environment
optimistic methods are really good to
get you to get the regret to go down
this is roughly speaking of intuition
and i think i should wrap it up here
with concave games
and you know i don't know if there are
any further questions but uh thank you
very much
[Applause]
mike
so it's a beautiful result first of all
very nice thank you um
when i think of very very smooth in
optimization i don't think of negative
momentum i think of momentum
i think of nestorof right and so on yes
and so i wondered if this result really
depends on the negative you know look
ahead kind of momentum
it does critically or is it also the
case that a nest draws style for each
agent would work or you've actually
shown that it doesn't
no with uh why is the smoothness so a
negative point right so that's a great
question remember recall my picture from
earlier right where gradient descent
dynamics spiral around and away from the
equilibrium if you add positive momentum
to that you're going to be spiraling
away even faster so inherently the
momentum is wrong
so you don't want to
you know momentum you want to fight the
momentum as opposed to uh you know uh
follow the momentum so that that that
that is what's going on pictorially
uh yeah i mean so it does critically
depend on
uh uh you know predicting it's a like
ultimately i mean okay like this here's
the slide
so
multiplicative weights update
so so so here we're in a game context so
we have to stay in the simplex so a nice
way to stay in the simplex is the
multiplicative updates what is
multiplicative updates
in every round player i at round t
player i assigns to action a
the same probability that we're
assigning before
with an exponential penalty
respect to the loss that this action
experienced in the last round in the
current rounds this is optimistic this
is multiplicative weights update
the optimistic version is exactly the
same code
except you do this prediction that i was
doing earlier like you you you really
you you predict the future loss that
this action will experience
with this you know like doubly counting
the most recent rounds and subtracting
the previous round so
you're anticipating what's going to
happen in the next round and this is
very critical
to prove this yeah so like uh
uh in particular if you do for example
multiple weights update you can you know
chen and peng showed that you cannot
improve the routine like this routine is
inherent there
and uh you know to improve it
you have to yeah you have to do that
more on the details of that so the the
intuition that stable and uh
optimistic it was there for the quarter
the improvement comes from using the
higher order correctness uh yes i mean
okay okay
so
exactly
no but i want to answer it specifically
to vasilis because the starting point is
his analysis
so um
so vasily showed that uh and company
showed that the regret that a player
experiences in t rounds
depends on
the uh
he has a different formula but this is
related
on uh how fast how much the losses that
the
the the the the distance traveled by the
law sequence which is this
effectively this
now in this upper bound there is this
other term which is uh the uh
losses
uh
and
so in the previous analysis this term
was ignored
and if you only use that you can still
improve the rates okay but now
what do you want to argue is that uh
effectively
you can kill this if you actually look
in the info in here
all right and that necessitates you to
uh
uh at least you know uh
a necessitates to consider higher order
uh uh
smoothness because kind of like in
higher order you can easily
you know in a higher order you can
easily establish that this distance
traveled is very small
and then you percolate that down to the
zero level roughly roughly roundly
thinking
okay
yes
oh yes
probably this is a question of people
that they love ftrl um
but i i'm asking it also because mike
asked about different kind of algorithms
that cancer that did you ever try to
apply any other
optimistic version of an ftrl to see if
this
regret is similar i want to understand
if for example the the negative entropic
regularizer that gives the
multiplicative weight update uh finally
is a critical point to to take this
logarithmic retreat uh okay yeah so okay
so i guess that's a great question first
of all and i should say that uh in
vasilis's result you don't need to use
specifically optimistic heads you can uh
you can use any method that you you know
that has negative momentum in a
particular sense
uh and for example you know like if you
do ftrl follow the regular leader
uh if you do any optimistic follow the
regularized leader method
under you know
some mild conditions you can get uh
you know this improvement okay
now for our proof
we currently critically use the
functional form
uh because sort of like when we analyze
higher order smoothness of the loss
sequence
we like the fact that we have this soft
max function here like this soft max
function is very nice
so we use that to prove higher order
smoothness for our dynamics
but that being said i believe that you
know you can extend this to
more general methods so that's an
interesting uh uh open question so
um
yeah
so
i believe you can extend this to more
general ftrl optimistic of the ftrl
methods
so i have two questions the first one is
about the analysis okay so if you
instead of optimistic
you do like higher order
can you kill the log to the fifth
oh uh higher order you mean
higher order differences
in your uh oh like in my prediction yeah
in your prediction look like you know
yesterday two days ago three days ago et
cetera
yeah exactly
if you can take the log to the fifth
have like one over t eventually uh right
with with like uh better predictions not
that not that i know uh not that i know
but i don't know max is here in the
audience maybe he knows okay and max is
you know uh like author in this favor
official so the other question in uh i
think it's also with for washing is for
the rvu type bound
if you have last iterate
you might have speed up in the regret so
like have faster average iterate
no as i was saying earlier commenting on
a line of work with no golovich
we know that the rates for last iterate
at least for these two methods right so
like optimistic grade and descent ascend
and uh extra gradient
must be slower so last time it is fewer
than average all i'm saying is that if
last i tell it
the fact that you have last iterate
can give you information about faster
average iterative oh i see i mean if you
see your lemma one in the right hand
side
right say that you you know that the
trajectories are a really really small
guy so you you will have small regret in
some sense so say that i know that you
have last iterate like optimistic yeah
maybe this is a reason why you know i
mean in high level you are conceptually
that you have low regrets because you
have the last iterate conversion uh yeah
conceptually conceptually conceptually
this is
you know this is what is you know taking
place in the background like one
interesting question is can you derive
for example last iterate for another
question
a bit of talking about yours but can you
derive last literally from this equation
that's another interesting question
yeah yeah
uh i don't know how to derive but i
haven't thought about it uh
too much
uh but but but yeah like intuitively
this is very well what could be taking
place
sure sure but you can write it for two
players as well right yeah okay sure so
let's take the rest of the discussion
offline uh so we're gonna have a two
hour break for lunch and then avatar is
gonna be speaking uh virtually uh she's
gonna be looking about journals and
games and value equilibrium learning as
a solution concept
uh we'll all be here who's gonna be
shown here you can either join here or
join you know virtually too but yeah
we're all going to be here and it's
going to be season thank you